el 20 o 25 % del país
con esas renovables.
Y no estoy diciendo que sea mala idea.
Sólo necesitamos entender los números.
No soy en absoluto anti-renovables. Me encantan las renovables.
Pero también soy pro-aritmética. (Risas)
Concentrar la energía solar en los desiertos ofrece
mayor potencia por unidad de área, porque no hay
problema de nubes,
así que este centro rinde 14 vatios por m2,
este 10 vatios por m2,
y este otro en España 5 vatios por m2.
Siendo generosos en la concentración de energía solar,
Creo que es perfectamente creíble un rendimiento de 20 vatios
por m2. Está bien.
Por supuesto, Gran Bretaña no tiene desiertos.
Aún. (Risas)
Así que este es el resumen hasta ahora.
Todas las renovables, por mucho que nos gusten, son difusas.
Todas tienen un pobre rendimiento por unidad de área,
y tenemos que vivir con ello.
Esto significa que si desean que las renovables
signifiquen una diferencia sustancial para un país como
el Reino Unido, a la escala de consumo de hoy,
se necesitan instalaciones de renovables
del tamaño de un país, no el país entero
pero sí una parte importante.
Hay otras opciones para generar energía
que no requieren combustibles fósiles.
Está la energía nuclear, y en este mapa cortesía de Ordnance Survey
pueden ver que hay un Sizewell B
dentro de un km2 azul.
Es un gigavatio en un km2,
que funciona a 1000 vatios por m2.
Por esta métrica en particular, la energía nuclear
no es tan intrusiva como las renovables.
Por supuesto, también cuentan otras mediciones, y la energía nuclear
tiene todo tipo de problemas de popularidad.
Pero lo mismo ocurre con las renovables.
Aquí está una fotografía de una consulta popular en pleno apogeo
en la pequeña ciudad de Penicuik a las afueras de Edimburgo,
y se puede ver a los niños de Penicuik festejando
la quema de una efigie del aerogenerador.
Las personas son anti-todo, tenemos que mantener
todas las opciones sobre la mesa.
¿Qué puede hacer un país como el Reino Unido en cuestión de suministros?
Bien, las opciones son, diría, estas tres:
fuentes renovables de energía, reconociendo que necesitan ser
casi del tamaño de un país; energías renovables de otros pueblos,
así podríamos volver y hablar muy amablemente al pueblo
de la parte superior izquierda del diagrama y decir:
"No queremos las energías renovables en nuestro patio,
¿pero, por favor, podríamos ponernos en el suyo?"
Y es una opción seria.
Es una manera mundial de tratar este asunto.
Así, países como Australia, Rusia, Libia, Kazajstán,
podrían ser nuestros mejores amigos para la producción de renovables.
Y una tercera opción es la energía nuclear.
Estas son las opciones.
Además de métodos de suministro que podríamos iniciar,
y recuerden que necesitamos grandes cantidades,
porque en este momento,
conseguimos el 90 % de nuestra energía de combustibles fósiles.
Además de estos métodos, podríamos hablar de otras maneras
de resolver este problema, por ejemplo, reducir la demanda,
y eso significa reducir la población
(no sé muy bien cómo hacer eso)
o reducir el consumo per cápita.
Así que vamos a hablar de tres mecanismos
que podrían ayudar en el consumo.
Primero, el transporte. Aquí están los principios físicos que te dicen
cómo reducir el consumo de energía de transporte.
La gente suele decir: "Sí, la tecnología puede responder todo.
Podemos hacer vehículos que sean cien veces más
eficientes". Y eso es casi cierto. Se los mostraré.
El consumo de energía de este tanque típico de aquí
es de 80 kilovatios por hora por cada cien kilómetros.
Como el coche europeo medio.
Ochenta kilovatios por hora. ¿Podemos hacer algo cien veces
mejor mediante la aplicación de los principios de física que enumeré?
Sí. Aquí está. Es la bicicleta. Es 80 veces mejor en consumo de energía
y es alimentado por biocombustibles, por Weetabix.
(Risas)
Hay otras opciones intermedias, porque tal vez
la dama en el tanque diría: "No, no, no,
eso es un cambio de estilo de vida. No cambien mi estilo de vida, por favor".
Bien. Podríamos convencerla de ir en tren,
que es mucho más eficiente que un coche,
pero podría ser un cambio de estilo de vida,
o hay eco-coches, arriba a la izquierda.
Acoge cómodamente un adolescente
es más corto que un cono de tráfico,
y casi tan eficiente como una bicicleta
mientras que conduzcas a 24 km/h.
Entre medias, tal vez algunas opciones más realistas
en este nivel de transporte son los vehículos eléctricos:
bicis eléctricas y coches eléctricos en el centro,
cuatro veces tan eficientes energéticamente
como el tanque de gasolina estándar.
A continuación, se encuentra la calefacción.
La calefacción supone un tercio de nuestro consumo de energía en Gran Bretaña,
y mucha va a los hogares
y otros edificios para su calefacción y el agua caliente.
Esta es una típica casa británica.
Es mi casa, con el Ferrari en la puerta.
¿Qué podemos hacer con ella?
Bueno, las leyes de la física están ahí escritas,
describen cómo el consumo de energía
para la calefacción se maneja por artilugios que se pueden controlar.
Pueden controlar la diferencia de temperatura
entre el interior y el exterior, gracias
a una notable tecnología llamada termostato.
Si lo giran a la izquierda,
disminuye su consumo de energía en el hogar.
Lo he probado. Funciona. Algunas personas lo llaman un cambio de estilo de vida.
También pueden instalar material aislante para reducir filtraciones
en su edificio: poner aislante en las paredes, en el techo,
una nueva puerta y así sucesivamente,
y la triste verdad es que esto le ahorrará dinero.
Que no es triste, eso es bueno, pero la triste verdad es, sólo se
reducen en un 25 % las filtraciones de su edificio,
si hacen estas cosas, que son buenas ideas.
Si realmente desean acercarse a los estándares suecos
de construcción con una casa como ésta,
es necesario poner aislamiento externo en el edificio
como se muestra en este conglomerado de apartamentos de Londres.
También pueden obtener calor más eficientemente con bombas de calor
que emplean menos energía eléctrica
para llevar calor desde su jardín a su casa.
La tercera opción de la que quiero hablar,
la tercera forma de reducir el consumo de energía es,
lean sus contadores.
La gente habla mucho de medidores inteligentes,
pero pueden hacerlo Uds. mismos.
Usen sus propios ojos y sean inteligentes; lean sus contadores,
y si son como yo, su vida cambiará.
Este es un gráfico que hice.
Estaba escribiendo un libro sobre energía sostenible
y un amigo me preguntó: "Bueno, ¿cuánta energía usas
en casa?". Y me avergoncé. No lo sabía.
Y empecé a leer el contador cada semana.
Las antiguas lecturas se muestran
en la mitad superior de la gráfica y 2007
se muestra en verde en la parte inferior, que fue cuando
leía el contador cada semana, y mi vida cambió,
porque empecé a hacer experimentos y ver
cuál era la diferencia, y mi consumo de gas
se desplomó porque empecé a jugar
con el termostato y el temporizador del sistema de calefacción,
y reduje más de la mitad en la factura del gas.
Hice algo similar con el consumo de electricidad,
apagando los reproductores de DVD, el estéreo,
los periféricos del PC que estaban encendidos todo el tiempo,
y sólo los encendía cuando los necesitaba
y reduje otro tercio mis facturas de electricidad.
Así que necesitamos un plan que sume, y he descrito para Uds.
seis grandes palancas; necesitamos grandes acciones porque obtenemos
el 90 % de nuestra energía de combustibles fósiles,
así que necesitan emplear la mayoría, si no todas esas palancas.
Y la mayoría de ellas son impopulares,
y si hay una palanca que no les guste usar
tengan en cuenta que eso supone
hacer más esfuerzos en las otras.
Así que soy un firme defensor de mantener conversaciones adultas
basadas en hechos y números, y quiero terminar
con este mapa en el que se visualizan
los requisitos de la tierra y demás para obtener
sólo 16 lámparas por persona
de cuatro de las grandes fuentes posibles.
Así que, si desean obtener 16 lámparas, recuerden,
hoy nuestro consumo total de energía es de 125 lámparas.
Si quieren 16 del viento, este mapa visualiza una solución
en el Reino Unido. Tiene 160 parques eólicos,
cada uno de 100 km2,
sería un aumento de veinte veces
sobre la cantidad de viento actual.
Con la energía nuclear, para obtener 16 lámparas por persona, necesitarían
dos gigavatios en cada uno de los puntos púrpuras en el mapa.
Es un aumento de cuatro veces
sobre los recursos actuales en energía nuclear.
En biomasa, para obtener 16 lámparas por persona, se necesita
una superficie de un tamaño de tres Gales y medio,
en nuestro país o en otro,
posiblemente Irlanda, posiblemente en otro lugar. (Risas)
Y una cuarta opción, concentrar la energía solar
en los desiertos de otra gente.
Si desean obtener 16 lámparas,
entonces estamos hablando de estos 8 hexágonos
en la parte inferior derecha.
El área total de los hexágonos
es de un Sáhara del doble del tamaño del Gran Londres,
y necesitarán tendido eléctrico por toda España
y Francia para llevar la energía desde el Sahara a Surrey.
Necesitamos un plan que sume.
Tenemos que dejar de gritar y empezar a hablar,
y si podemos tener una conversación adulta,
hacer un plan de suma y empezar a construir,
quizá esta revolución de reducción de uso del carbono
sea hasta divertida. Muchas gracias por escucharme.
(Aplausos)